ces pompiers russes tentent d'éteindre
l'incendié qui ravage cet entrepôt de
pétrole de belgorod le gouverneur de la
région affirment que deux hélicoptères
ou ukrainiens ont frappé le site dans la
nuit et que ces images de caméras de
surveillance montrent un tir de roquette
belgorod se trouve à moins de 50
kilomètres de la frontière avec
l'ukraine depuis le début de la guerre
c'est la première fois que moscou accusé
kiev d'une frappe aérienne sur son
territoire de son côté le gouvernement
ukrainien n'a pas confirmé ou nié être à
l'origine de la tacc
l'ukraine mènent des opérations de
défense pour résister à l'agression
militaire russe sur le territoire
ukrainien
cela ne signifie pas que l'ukraine doit
assumer la responsabilité de toutes les
erreurs de calcul
toutes les catastrophes et tous les
événements ayant lieu sur le territoire
russe
je ne peux ni confirmer ni démentir
cette information
en ukraine de nombreux observateurs
craignent qu'il s'agisse là d'une
opération sous fausse bannière pour
justifier une nouvelle opération
militaire russe ou en interrompre les
discussions qui viennent de reprendre
entre kiev et moscou
il est évident qu'on ne peut pas
considérer cela comme quelque chose
qu'il a créé les conditions appropriées
pour l'aperçu des négociations
les autorités russes affirment que l'
incendie du dépôt de belgorod ne
provoquera pas de pénurie de pétrole
dans la région le site est l'une des
principales sources d'approvisionnement
pour les unités russes déployées en
ukraine